in history of Science Museum in Florence
Italy is the middle finger of our modern
age I've been lucky enough to actually
go to this museum and it is incredible
and in there among the armillary spheres
and the lodestones and the antique
telescopes there is a literal piece of
humanity a middle finger and it is kept
in a little shrine like a saintly relic
but this is not a piece of a saint it is
a piece of an enemy of the church it is
part of a heretic this is Galileo's
middle finger it took a while for
Galileo's skeleton to age into something
worth collecting sort of like a like a
fine wine so it wasn't until 17 37 or 95
years after he died that one Anton
Francesco gory went and decided that he
needed to collect a few pieces of
Galileo Galilei now this wasn't without
a precedent there was a long tradition
of preserving venerated individuals in
Catholicism if this was a little
different
Anton Francesco Gori was not a religious
fanatic he was a Galileo groupie what he
did is he snapped off three fingers and
a few other bits which we'll get into
later he took his thumb his index finger
and his middle finger is is this your
index finger he was taking scientific
relics these were the fingers that
Galileo used when he adjusted his
telescope he was in essence creating the
first scientific Saint often times
Galileo is portrayed as being versus the
church it was Galileo in the church in
this you know pit match against each
other it was a little more complicated
than that
Galileo wanted to write a book on
heliocentrism his theory that the earth
did in fact revolve around the Sun and
not the other way around and the church
actually said okay that's fine
but just you got to represent both sides
of the argument so Galileo did this but
the guy who represented the church in
its geocentric position did such a
terrible job that when the book was
published people basically thought that
Galileo had punked the Pope after this
the Pope who is already paranoid and
worried about looking weak came down and
sentenced Galileo to house arrest
basically for the remainder of his life
but it doesn't mean that Galileo ever
truly abandoned his faith ultimately
whether Galileo's middle finger is
pointed up at the heavens where he saw
the beauty of God in math and physics or
out to the church who condemned him for
his scientific views is really for the
viewer to decide his thumb and other
finger were also taken and they actually
weren't discovered until 2009 when they
were seen on an auction block and
someone put it together and was like I
feel like these are the other two
fingers that have been missing so they
have been reunited as has a tooth and if
you are on a Galileo corpse tour of
Italy you should go to the University of
Padua because they've got his vertebrae